It's the most wonderful time of the year!
The 12,020 human space era calendar has arrived.
You can order it now until we sell out,
and then never again.
In the last few years, we've
looked back at the achievements of our
ancestors that paved the way for our
modern world more than
ten thousand years ago.
This year, we'll turn our gaze to the future of humanity
and how we will explore space
in the next ten thousand years.
Twelve illustrations will take you
to the liquid-gas oceans on Titan,
colonies on Mars,
the storm clouds on Uranus,
and many more stops
on humanity's biggest journey yet.
Enjoy solar system-wide delivery, shipping from the US and finally, also from Europe.
Order now to get our limited-edition
calendar in time for the holidays to
make your kids, family, and friends happy
or to distract yourself from the looming void within.
You know, whatever works for you.
You can get the calendar together with a duck plushie, a hoodie, or a poster, if you want;
we've put together a few deals.
Thank you so much to the thousands
of people who got the calendar last year.
Because of you, we can keep this channel
free for everyone and make even more beautiful things.
A happy interstellar year, 12,020!
*Quieter Kurzgesagt jingle*
*howls*